MEDIA.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
LAST NIGHT I TOLD YOU HOW THE
PRESIDENT EXPOSED THE DEMOCRATS'
TRUE SHUTDOWN MOTIVES,
NAMELY THE DEMOCRATS LOVE THE
PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT HELPS THEM
POLITICALLY.
WHICH IS WHY THEY REFUSE TO MOVE
EVEN AN INCH ON THE ISSUE OF
WALL FUNDING.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT EXPOSED THE
MEDIA'S MOTIVES IN THIS DRAMA AS
WELL.
RATHER THAN GIVING US IN-DEPTH
OBJECTIVE REPORTING ON THE
EFFECTS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
ON AVERAGE AMERICANS, ALL OF
YOU OUT THERE, YOUR JOBS, YOUR
SCHOOLS, YOUR SAFETY, AND ON
YOUR HEALTH, THE MEDIA SPEND
THEIR AIRTIME PARROTING DEMOCRAT
ATTACKS ON THE PRESIDENTS
CHARACTER AND MOTIVES.
>> HIS WHOLE FRAME AROUND THIS
ENTIRE DEBATE, THE ENTIRE
SHUTDOWN, THE ENTIRE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN, OVER A SCAM.
THIS IS NOT A BORDER SECURITY
CRISIS THAT MERITS A WALL.
IT'S A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
>> WHERE THE PRESIDENT WAS
INCREDIBLY DISINGENUOUS BECAUSE
HE SAID THAT THE SHUTDOWN IS
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS WILL NOT FIND
BORDER SECURITY.
THAT'S JUST FALSE.
>> Laura: BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH LAST NIGHT,
THE MEDIA VOWED TO DO THEIR
INSTANT FACT-CHECKING.
THEY WANTED TO DO THIS IN REAL
TIME.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PREPARING HIS
PRIME TIME SPEECH AS
FACT-CHECKERS PREPARE FOR THEIR
VERSION OF THE SUPER BOWL.
>> THE PRIME TIME PITCH FROM THE
PRESIDENT THAT IS EXPECTED TO
SEND FACT-CHECKERS INTO
OVERDRIVE TONIGHT.
>> WE ARE ALL GOING TO BE DOING
FACT-CHECKING.
HERE AT CNN.
>> THEY HAVE REALLY BEEN
THROWING A LOT OF DODGY AND
FALSE STATISTICS AROUND.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE?
>> >> WE'LL BE FACT-CHECKING
RELENTLESSLY.
>> Laura: THE FACT CHECK SQUAD
DIDN'T FARE TOO WELL.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE HAD THE MOD
SQUAD.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
OVAL OFFICE ADDRESS, THE MEDIA
COLLAPSED INTO OLD TROOPS AND
SOME AWKWARD ADMISSIONS.
>> ONE AND THREE WOMEN ARE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN SOME WAY
ON THE JOURNEY.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
I CAN'T WEIGH IN.
>> EVERYDAY CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL AGENTS IN COUNTER
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
TRYING TO ENTER OUR COUNTRY.
>> SO HERE IS THE FACT.
THE FACT IS, WHILE BORDER
APPREHENSIONS WERE UP IN OCTOBER
AND NOVEMBER, THAT'S NOT
UNUSUAL.
>> HE WAS DELIVERING HIS SPEECH.
IT WAS SO LOW-ENERGY THAT OF
DONALD TRUMP WERE RUNNING
AGAINST THAT GUY, HE WOULD CALL
HIM LOW-ENERGY DAWN.
>> HE WAS THE FIRST EVER
PRESIDENTIAL ADDRESS VIA
COLLAPSED SOUFFLE.
HE LOOKED DEFEATED, DEFLATED.
HE LOOKED TERRIBLE.
>> Laura: IF I WAS AT CROWD I
WOULDN'T TALK ABOUT LOOKING
TERRIBLE.
FIRST OF ALL, FIRST OF ALL, WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE FACT-CHECK?
HE SAID THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS.
IT DEVOLVED INTO HE LOOKED
TIRED.
WELL, THEIR LATEST TACTIC AND
WERE GOING TO SEE MORTGAGE IN
THE COMING DAYS IS TO FEATURE
THE SOB STORIES OF GOVERNMENT
WORKERS WHO, STILL BY THE WAY,
HAVE NOT MISSED A PAYCHECK.
WATCH CAREFULLY.
RANK EMOTIONAL MANIPULATION,
PURE PROPAGANDA.
NOW, HOW MANY OF THESE SEGMENTS
TODAY DO OVER THE YEARS ON
AMERICAN WORKERS WHO PUSHED OUT
-- WERE PUSHED OUT OF ENTIRE
INDUSTRIES AS UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS HIRE THEM FOR CASH OR
AT A FRACTION OF THE
SALARY.
HOW MANY CLOSE-UP INTERVIEWS OF
DEMONS OF ILLEGAL ALIEN CRIME
DID THEY DO?
BY THE WAY, THOSE PEOPLE AREN'T
EXPERIENCING A TEMPORARY LOSS OF
INCOME.
BUT A PERMANENT LOSS OF A FAMILY
MEMBER.
LOOK AT THE FRONT PAGE OF
TODAY'S "NEW YORK TIMES" WHICH
THOUGHT TO FRAME THE PRESIDENT'S
ADDRESS THIS WAY.
YOU SEE THE PHOTO.
IT'S A PHOTO OF MIGRANTS, YOU
CAN SEE THERE.
IT'S GETTING SMALLER MIGRANTS AT
A TIJUANA TEMPORARY KIND OF
MIGRANT SHELTER.
ONCE AGAIN, THE MEDIA FOCUSING
ON THAT, INTERVIEWING PEOPLE AT
THE SHELTER, PUTTING BOTH
FEELINGS AND THE CONCERNS OF
NONCITIZENS OVER THOSE OF ACTUAL
CITIZENS.
AT LEAST THEY HAVE THAT NICE
WHITE SCREEN.
THEY COULD ENJOY IT ON THAT.
PERHAPS THE VOTERS AFTER
WATCHING ALL THIS, HEARING ALL
OF IT, ARE NOT SO EASILY
MANIPULATE IT.
THEY MORNING POLL FOUND A
PLURALITY OF AMERICANS, 42%,
BELIEVE THE SITUATION AT THE
BORDERS OF CRISIS, INCLUDING 72%
OF REPUBLICANS.
OBVIOUSLY FAR FEWER DEMOCRATS.
TRUMP HAS SUCCESSFULLY SHUNNED
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT SUBSTANCE
THE ENGAGED IN PROBLEM SOLVING
ON THE ISSUE AT THE BORDER.
BUT STILL THE MEDIA CONTINUES TO
CARRY THE WATER FOR THEM.
BUT WHEN REPORTERS BEGIN ACTING
LIKE PUNDITS, KELLYANNE CONWAY
SHOWED US YESTERDAY EXACTLY HOW
THEY SHOULD BE TREATED.
>> CAN YOU PROMISE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILL TELL THE TRUTH
TONIGHT?
WILL HE TELL THE TRUTH?
>> YES, CAN YOU PROMISE THAT YOU
WILL?
THE WHOLE TRUTH AND NOTHING BUT
THE TRUTH, SO HELP YOU GOD.
MAKE SURE THAT GOES VIRAL.
THIS IS WHY I'M ONE OF THE ONLY
PEOPLE AROUND HERE WHO EVEN
GIVES YOU THE TIME OF DAY.
LET ME GET BACK IN YOUR FACE
BECAUSE YOU'RE SUCH A [BLEEP]
I KNOW YOU WANT THIS TO GO
VIRAL.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
YOU.
LET ME BE RESPECTFUL TO THE
MEDIA WRIT LARGE AS I ALWAYS ON.
I EXPLAINED THAT IT WITH
ALTERNATIVE INFORMATION AND
ADDITIONAL FACTS MAKES PLANET
MANY TIMES.
DON'T YOU PUT HER BACK IN MY
FACE FOR ALL THE QUESTIONS YOUR
NETWORK NEEDS TO ISSUE.
>> Laura: SHE SAID SMART ASS.
IT WAS ALL OVER TELEVISION
YESTERDAY.
SHE OBVIOUSLY HAS BEEN LEARNING
FOR HER BOSS A LITTLE BIT.
HERE IS THE TRUMP SMACK DOWN OF
ABC'S JONATHAN KARL THAT
HAPPENED TODAY IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AS THE PRESIDENT WAS
ACTUALLY DOING THE BUSINESS
OF THE COUNTRY, THE SERIES OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING BILLS WERE
SIGNED.
>> I NOT SIGN THE OTHER BILLS,
SOME OF THESE WORKERS CAN GET
PAID.
>> DO YOU THINK I SHOULD DO
THAT?
DO YOU THINK I SHOULD DO THAT,
JOHN?
I WANT YOUR ONE-SIDED REPORTING.
DO YOU THINK I SHOULD DO THAT?
SERIOUSLY, JOHN, DO YOU THINK I
SHOULD JUST SIGN?
NO, NO, TELL ME.
JOHN, DO YOU THINK I SHOULD JUST
SIGN?
>> I AM SAYING THAT IF YOU SIGN
IT, WORKERS CAN START GETTING
PAID.
>> SO YOU WOULD DO THAT IF IF
>> SO YOU WOULD DO THAT IF IY
>> SO YOU WOULD DO THAT IF IU
ARE IN MY POSITION.
>> I'M NOT IN YOUR POSITION.
>> YOU SHOULD NEVER BE IN THIS
POSITION BECAUSE HE WOULD NEVER
GET ANYTHING DONE.
GOODBYE, EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, THE
BILLS ARE ACTUALLY SIGNED, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHICH ALL THESE
OTHER ADMINISTRATIONS WERE GOING
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT, TRUMP IS
ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
IT WHILE ALL THE OTHER STUFF IS
GOING ON AROUND HIM.
WOMEN'S EMPOWERMENT, DEMOCRATS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE ALL FOR THAT.
FUNDING FOR ALL SORTS OF WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURSHIP PROGRAMS.
IVANKA TRUMP HAS BEEN WORKING ON
THAT.
THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW AS
WELL.
DIDN'T MATTER.
NOT GOING TO COVER IT.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO PLAY THE PUNDIT
GAME WITH THE PRESIDENT.
TRUMP IS DOMINATING RHETORICALLY
AND SUBSTANTIVELY.
TOMORROW HE HEADS TO THE BORDER.
HE'S GOING TO AGAIN I PREDICT
TAKE CONTROL OF THE NEW CYCLE.
TODAY HE ACTUALLY WENT TO
CAPITOL HILL AND HE MET WITH
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE BEFORE THAT.
AGAIN, THE DEMOCRATS WERE NOT
INTERESTED THOUGH IN SOLUTIONS.
ONLY IN THE SOUND BITES
AFTERWARDS.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THE PRESIDENT
JUST GOT UP AND WALKED OUT.
HE JUST WALKED OUT.
AGAIN, WE SAW A TEMPER TANTRUM.
BECAUSE HE COULDN'T GET HIS WAY
AND HE JUST WALKED OUT OF THE
MEETING.
>> Laura: OKAY, NO.
THE PRESIDENT DECIDED THAT HE
HAD HAD ENOUGH.
THE DEMOCRATS JUST AREN'T
OPERATING IN GOOD FAITH HERE, SO
THE PRESIDENT WALKED OUT,
REFUSING TO BE PART OF THEIR
SHUT DOWN SOAP OPERA.
HE WANTS TO GET TO YES.
THEY WANT TO STAY AT NO.
OF ALL THE MEDIA OUTLETS OUT
THERE, THE AP WAS ONE OF THE
FIELD TO PROPERLY FRAME THE
SITUATION IN A TWEET, THEY WROTE
"DEMOCRATS PUT THE BLAME FOR THE
SHUTDOWN ON TRUMP, BUT IT TAKES
TWO TO TANGO.
TRUMP'S DEMANDS $5.7 BILLION FOR
HIS BORDER WALL IS ONE REASON
FOR THE BUDGET IMPASSE.
THE DEMOCRATS REFUSED TO APPROVE
THE MONEY IS ANOTHER."
GUESS WHAT, THE AP WAS LASHED BY
LIBERALS FOR DOING THAT.
THAT TWEET.
LOOK AT THE ONLINE REACTION.
LOOKS LIKE MY TWITTER FEED.
AP FACT-CHECK.
HINDENBURG WAS A FINE BLEND AND
DEMOCRATS TO FAIL TO APPRECIATE
IT BECAUSE IT TAKES TWO TO
TANGO.
AP FACT-CHECK.
AUTHORITIES PUT THE BLAME FOR
HANNIBAL LECTOR'S MURDER SPREE
ON THE SERIAL KILLER HIMSELF.
BUT IT TAKES TWO TO TANGO.
AMAZING.
WHILE, TRUMP CONTINUES TO BE A
POWERFUL POLITICAL ASTRINGENT AS
I LIKE TO SAY.
IN THE FACE OF POLITICS, AS
USUAL, IT'S FEELING THE STING
ESPECIALLY THE ONES THAT WE SAW
LAST NIGHT.
WELL, IT AIN'T PRETTY.
THE REAL COLLUSION, MY FRIENDS,
IS IN WASHINGTON AND IS THE ONE
THAT TRUMP HAD SO MASSIVELY
EXPOSED.